vous êtes un des acteurs français les
plus en vue mais vous avez accepté le
défi d'incarner Romain Gary dans le
chien blanc d'Anaïs Barbot La Valette on
m'a glissé à l'oreille que vous êtes
devenu obsédé par Romain Gary vous avez
écouté de nombreuses entrevues pour
pouvoir l'incarner comment ça s'est
passé pour vous c'était à la fameuse
époque du covid où j'étais enfermé
pendant 7 jours à mon arrivée ici
donc j'ai mis des photos de Romain Gary
partout dans la cuisine dans les
toilettes sur le frigo j'écoutais des
interviews des archives en boucle en
espérant réussir à décoder Romain Gary
et je ne suis pas arrivé du tout mais
j'ai mis du temps 16 jours je devais
complètement fou c'est vrai en plus
d'Anaïs était sur le balcon d'à côté à
l'avait loué la part d'à côté pour qu'on
se parle donc c'était pathétique j'ai
complètement dans mon truc mais ça va
oui si je devais écrire un livre ce
serait d'abord pour questionner ma place
d'hommes blancs dans ce combat pour
l'égalité vous avez tourné chez un blanc
au Québec mais vous avez aussi tourné
des appoints
de tourner avec une équipe de québécoise
on a l'impression d'être un peu comme si
on est avec des Ewoks où tout le monde
est gentil tout le monde est fait la
fête c'est que mais vraiment
et puis il y a des trucs de langage qui
m'ont beaucoup amusé à un moment il y a
mon ami bensu qui faisait le point sur
une scène où voilà où j'étais au
téléphone et puis bon ça coupe et fait
c'était que je fais c'était que c'était
vexé c'était pas bien ça veut dire que
c'était bien c'est que d'accord ok
[Musique]
votre carrière a vraiment décoller en
2009 avec cette fameuse scène mythique
dans le commando des bâtards de Quentin
Tarantino une scène a glacé le sang ou
vous incarnez un juif qui est interrogé
par un nazi physique on voit l'alarme à
l'oeil et pour avoir cette émotion là
quantaine terrain of the souffler
quelque chose à l'oreille et ça ça vous
rentre encore aujourd'hui alors pour vos
cousins québécois que vous a-t-il dit je
peux pas c'est ma cuisine c'est mes
recettes
il m'a donné le cadeau de l'émotion au
cinéma ça c'est vrai et je le garde pour
moi parce que ce genre de choses quand
on en parle ça disparaît c'est magique
donc excusez-moi je mais moi il m'a fait
ce cadeau live vraiment donner le cadeau
de l'émotion au cinéma et je vais grâce
à cette clé je peux aller dans l'émotion
alors que s'il n'avait pas donné ça je
pense que ma pudeur en tant qu'homme
souvent on pleure pas au cinéma les
garçons faut ça pleurent pas etc en tout
cas dans les émotions que même pour la
colère et pour plein de choses c'est un
vrai cadeau qui m'a fait mais regarde il
est encore avec des gosses je croyais
qu'il était mort
il va falloir faire quelque chose faut
réunir d'autres victimes en 2019 vous
avez remporté un César pour le meilleur
second rôle pour le film grâce à Dieu
dans votre ami François Ozon ça aussi ça
doit être difficile à incarner parce que
vous jouez justement une victime d'un
prêtre pédophile alors comment on habite
ce personnage là et comment on incarne
l'émotion tout en même temps respectueux
pour toutes ces victimes là comment on
habite est un très bon terme
non en fait si vous voulez ce sont des
gens qui sont encore en activité qui
sont ma génération qui avait cette
association là et en fait rien que de
lire les témoignages de tout ce qu'ils
avaient rassemblés de tout ce qui
s'était passé
c'est atroce c'est à dire qu'on était
dans une forme de lutte on représentait
le film un service d'espèces de chambres
déco à toutes ces voix qui s'élevaient
et non seulement on a fait trembler
l'église et tant mieux parce que ça a
vraiment fait bouger les choses on a été
très fier de ça mais
il y a plein de gens qui sont venus vers
nous pour parler de ça pour parler de ce
qu'il aurait été arrivé dans ce cours
dans la rue éclate en sanglots vous
prenne dans les bras vous dites merci
merci j'ai pu parler à ma femme de ce
qui m'était arrivé voilà c'est une vraie
fierté Julien elle est où
visiblement les rôles facile pour vous
c'est pas votre tasse de thé parce que
dans jusqu'à la garde 2019 16h du
meilleur film vous incarnez un père
violent ça aussi on vous sort
nécessairement de votre zone de confort
parce que des fois vous jouez les
martyrs d'autres fois les bourreaux j'ai
l'impression que le cinéma c'est soit on
est poursuivi soit on est celui qui
poursuit l'homme j'ai remarqué que si on
ramifie les choses c'est soit ou
poursuivez ou soit vous êtes poursuivi
j'ai l'impression mais encore une fois
c'est pour celui-là c'est une vraie
fierté parce que ça a dédié les langues
parce que les gens sont rendus compte
que quand on entend quelqu'un crier dans
l'immeuble d'à côté bon on va aller voir
on va pas attendre que ça se passe et
encore une fois c'est le témoignage de
toutes ces femmes qui a fait que j'ai pu
extraire un comportement
pour faire ce personnage et d'ailleurs
je me pose toujours la question de la
testostérone et du rôle qu'elle joue
dans le côté qui aveugle les hommes sur
leur jugement et leur potentiel à faire
du mal à des gens plus faibles que
denisha merci pour cette visite au
Québec j'espère bientôt vous revoir
merci beaucoup merci